l'observation que je suis sûr vous avez
fait que j'ai fait depuis longtemps
c'est que l'échelle de temps de l'action
politique en démocratie médiatique est
extrêmement raccourcis il m'est arrivé
d'écrire ya longtemps que la chine et
dieu sait que je n'envie pas le système
politique de la chine que la chine
réfléchissez à 30 ans et nous parfois à
30 jours tant la pression de l'actualité
des chaînes de télévision continue des
articles de journaux des sondages des
réseaux sociaux tant cette pression est
forte irrésistible assez souvent quand
vous êtes en situation de responsabilité
et que vous êtes
à l'instant jugé par ses instruments
divers mise en cause
ciblez naturellement votre préoccupation
aller d'améliorer votre situation
immédiate vis-à-vis de l'opinion de fer
que vos concitoyens et la meilleure
opinion de vous de sorte que jamais la
phrase célèbre de la constitution
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple n'a été en réalité aussi
vrai mais évidemment la pression de
l'instant elle détourne les responsables
publics de réfléchir à la audrey
horizons de la réaction à la vraie
échelle de temps de la réaction et c'est
la raison pour laquelle depuis longtemps
j'ai plaidé pour qu'on fasse renaître au
sein de nos institutions
cette idée de plan j'ai repris le mot de
jean monnet mais enfin 2 charles de
gaulle sur jean monnet de de gaulle sur
jean monnet mais naturellement c'est
plus le plan contraignant que
on a pu imaginer ou voir naître en union
soviétique ou qu'on voit aujourd'hui se
dérouler en chine
le plan à 30 ans je suis sûr que vous
êtes intéressé aux plans à 30 ans de
lachy c'est c'est un document qui n'est
pas seulement une réflexion qui est
décisions sur des objectifs chiffrés à
remplir avec des échelles de temps à
absolument fisc de fixer donc voilà le
voilà notre notre sujet et caen alors
pendant très longtemps
cette idée a été humide et très
minoritaire et puis l'épidémie en tout
cas le premier acte de l'épidémie a
prouvé que faute d'avoir réfléchi à ce
terme nous n'étions pas prêts et on
s'est trouvé comme vous le savez en
menacer de deux ruptures de médicaments
essentiels de médicaments pour
l'anesthésié de médias de
d'anti-inflammatoires d'antibiotiques de
et de molécules aussi
répandue que le doliprane par exemple le
paracétamol et donc ça a été une prise
de conscience ça a été une prise de
conscience pour les français qui ont
découvert stupéfaits
cette dépendance ce qui prouve que les
mots qu'on répète à longueur de temps
que moi j'avais l'impression de répéter
à longueur de temps depuis longtemps
sont pas toujours entendus mais cette
dépendance était évidemment une limite à
l'idéal de souveraineté qui est le nôtre
et simplement à ce qu'on doit aux
citoyens et donc
à cette époque le président de la
république a dit qu' il fallait aux
faucons qu'on remette ses sujets à
l'ordre du jour et il m'a donc confié
moi j'avais plaidé depuis longtemps je
savais aucune idée que ce serait moi je
vous assure je me voyais plutôt dans une
autre fonction à l'époque est donc est
donc présenté république m'a dit mais
vous allez le faire alors nous avons
conduit des réflexions depuis le moment
où on a été installé droit dans dont un
certain nombre ont fait un peu de bruit
bienvenue la première c'est une
réflexion sur le sujet et si le coc vide
bure et c'est la seule qui a été
produite en europe à cette époque et
d'ailleurs j'en ai pas vus depuis
souvent parce que notre intuition c'est
que cette épidémie changer en profondeur
un certain nombre de données et de
tendances lourdes de la société dans
laquelle nous vivons
par exemple le fait que nous soyons une
société à 6 1 cassis son développement
depuis plus de cent ans sur la
croissance exponentielle des échanges et
l'élargissement exponentielle de
l'espace pour ces échanges qui attend
profité à l'extrême orient la chine à la
dette c'est le la la tante de l'opinion
sur des périmètres des changes
plus réduit c'est un jeu c'est une
donnée qui va jouer un rôle très
important
de la même manière il ya un certain
nombre de chose qui moi mon nous ont
frappés depuis le début qui sont le
changement des modes de vie des
habitudes le fait qu' on ne s'embrasse
plus alors que tout le monde s'embrasse
et qu'on ne se visitent plus qu' on ne
voyage plus pendant toute cette période
le fait que les grandes unités urbaines
je suis certain que ça vous a frappé
aussi les grandes unités urbaines sont
un plus
redorant femmes suscite plus
d'inquiétude et de suspicion alors
qu'autrefois les intérêts une attraction
formidable mais d'autres territoires
avec moins de pression démographique
vont devenir plus attractifs tout ça
c'était le c'était le première premiers
grands sujets de réflexion parce que
nous croyons nous avons avancé l'idée
que ça n'était pas seulement du point de
vue économique du point de vue des
échanges du point de vue des modes de
vie mais qu'il y avait là quelque chose
qui change et du point de vue
anthropologique
nous vivions dans un univers où les où
les êtres humains au féminin et au
masculin était dans en réalité dans une
confiance absolue les heurts avec des
autres et l'épidémie tout d'un coup elle
crée quelque chose comme une précaution
une réticence un soupçon quelque chose
de cet ordre le faites vous le savez
bien qu'aujourd'hui la première question
quand on rencontre quelqu'un c'est est
ce que vous êtes vacciné et d'ailleurs
on n'y a pas manqué quand nous sommes
quand je suis entré dans la salle nous
nous sommes adressés les uns aux autres
cette question tout ça c'est parce que
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
alors d'ici peu d'ici quelques mois
probablement des questions se poseront
donc le pass and i ter enfants tous que
tout ce que nous devinons ça c'était
deux premiers sujets de préoccupation
après on s'est intéressé à
l'interruption de ces circuits de
distribution de médicaments et
d'approvisionnement et de production et
de fabrication et
et quelles étaient les les grands
secteurs qui sont des secteurs de
souveraineté et quelle réflexion peut
susciter le fait que pendant trente ans
on a laissé filer tout ça qu un pays
comme le nôtre réputé grands pays
industriels grands pays pharmaceutique
grands pays développés grands pays
médical grands pays technologique que ce
grand pays et laissé en réalité pendant
30 ans ce qui fait que personne ne peut
faire de procès à personne pendant 30
ans en tout cas ne peut se limiter à un
procès pendant trente ans on a laissé
peu à peu filer déménager comme s'ils
s'étaient introduits dans les esprits
l'idée je vous devez employer le mot
ultra libérale parce qu'il est trop
simpliste mais l'idée que s'agissant en
particulier de l'économie
l'intérêt général n'étaient pas autre
chose que la somme des intérêts
particuliers les entreprises qu'il
suffisait de laisser décider les
entreprises et que l'intérêt général
serais satisfait et c'est ainsi je vais
pas le dire devant vous parce que vous
connaissez ça aussi bien que moi et
mieux peut-être l'idée que
de deux très grands secteurs
technologiques nous est complètement
échappé finalement avec l'assentiment et
implicite de tout le monde et des
pouvoirs publics en particulier pour moi
c'est une très grande question très
grande question sur laquelle nous sommes
revenus dans d'autres études par exemple
nous avons fait une étude sur la dette
je vous entendez dire que vous alliez
vous y intéresser aussi où nous avons
distinguer deux sortes de dette la dette
liée directement à l'épidémie de covin
comme g herria gens pleins terme coville
au masculin parce que le mot disease en
anglais est un mot neutre c'est pas
c'est pas mauvais monde féminin donc en
dépit des injonctions se défend l'idée
qu'on a le droit de dire que vu dont
masculin
et donc cette cette épidémie là elle a
induit un certain nombre de dépenses de
soutien aux pays aux familles aux
individus aux entreprises à d'activité
et j'ai qualifié cette dette de dettes
de guerre il ya des moments dans
lorsqu'un pays est attaqué il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de s'endetter
d'emprunter pour se défendre pour
acheter des armes pour soutenir les
industries ont dirigé vers la guerre est
ce que tous les pays ont fait nôtre en
particulier il ya une deuxième dette qui
me paraît absolument nécessaire et
indispensable de préparer d'envisager de
réfléchir c'est la dette lié à ce qui me
paraît vital c'est à dire la reconquête
de la production laisse pas si on
regarde ce qu'est la france
la france un pays qui bâtit ont dit
classiquement autour d'une langue et
d'un état ce qui est absolument vrai
mais en réalité quand on regarde la
situation de la france c'est un pays qui
est bâti autour de son contrat social de
la solidarité qu'on se doit les uns aux
autres à tous les moments de la vie
or la question qui se pose en face de ce
contrat social qui s'est montré encore
dans cette crise je crois qu'on peut
dire le plus généreux au monde
la question qui se pose c'est sa soupe
ou soutenabilité est-ce que nous avons
les moyens de le financer
et si nous voulons le financer alors il
faut que
on se lance dans une entreprise de tout
premier plan qui est la reconquête des
secteurs de production que nous avons
abandonné parce que là réside l'emploi
la création de richesse la création des
ressources qui permettent dessus de de
soutenir le contrat social or ce grant
le grand investissement qui est
nécessaire que nous n'avons pas fait
depuis des décennies car il ya des
décennies que l'état français emprunte
pour le fonctionnement ne pas vos
investissements
c'est comme vous savez bien
de ce point de vue là un déséquilibre
absolument incroyable pour des
gestionnaires le gestionnaire de
collectivités locales que nous sommes où
nous avons été les uns et les autres
sont effarés quand il voit le
déséquilibre entre fonctionnement et
investissement dans dans les emprunts
dans les emprunts de l'état et donc j'ai
dit que après la dette de guerre quand
nous sortirions de l'épidémie alors il
fallait envisager un plan marshall j'ai
utilisé d'expression de l'après deuxième
guerre mondiale
sauf que le plan marshall été financée
par des crédits américain est largement
au bénéfice des américains mais que nous
nous devions avoir des investissements
qui seraient financés par notre propre
effort et nous proposions qu' on puisse
avoir un différé d'amortissement de dix
ans de manière que on puisse se lancer
avec confiance dans la nécessité de
rétablissement de reconquête de notre
appareil productif industriels agricoles
et tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'agroalimentaire
je pense évidemment aux ressources
halieutiques aussi et de services et que
ce grand souvent chapitre de l'action
nationale devait être envisagée dans
notre rapport nous avions dit un peu à
la louche jallet vie qu'il faudrait 250
milliards pour se lancer dans ce travail
là depuis sont sortis les chiffres des
états unis puisque biden a décidé de
mettre 2200 milliards de plus
et si vous rapportez à la dimension des
économies on est dans l'ordre de
grandeurs de ce que nous avions évalué
nous mêmes
ça c'était le sujet de préoccupation
nous sommes passés ensuite toujours dans
la fidélité à la mission qui est fixé
par le décret la lettre de mission que
vous avez rappelé comment identifier les
grands sujets d'avenir dont personne ne
se préoccupe et donc pourtant notre
avenir dépend la vie de la nation dépend
son passé à l'énergie pour observer qu'
il y avait beaucoup de discours autour
de la décarbonation
à juste titre si l'on considère que
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre et la
donnée fondamentale aujourd'hui de ce
que l'humanité doit affronter en matière
de changements climatiques et s'il est
important de baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet serre comme nous nous y
sommes engagés dans des accords
internationaux
alors ça veut dire que il faut se
préoccuper de la production d'énergies
décarbonées et que ça va être le grand
sujet des années qui viennent et le
grand sujet se traduit extrêmement
simplement pour toutes les familles
c'est que tous les instituts toutes les
commissions nationales et
internationales disent que le
le point d'inflexion c'est une
utilisation beaucoup plus large de
l'électricité électricité pour la
mobilité
la présidente de de la commission
comment s'appelle la commission
le haut conseil pour le climat dit il
faut électrifié toutes les voitures
individuelles d'ici à vingt ans et c'est
la même réflexion s'applique dans les
autres pays
alors s'il faut électrifié toutes les
voitures individuelles s'il faut
s'occuper des transports en commun j'ai
créé à pau la première ligne au monde de
transport en commun bhns à hydrogène
savage très bien mais ça pose évidemment
des questions de production de
l'électricité qui doit être verte
enfin qu'il doit être sans émissions de
gaz à effet de serre décarbonés et est
donc cette question-là plus le chauffage
des logements ayant en tête que
l'électricité c'est en effet le seul
moyen de ne pas émettre de gaz à effet
de serre là où elle est utilisée mais
encore faut-il que la production de
cette électricité soit elle-même
respectueuse de nos engagements de
décarbonation et donc ça conduit à peu
près tout le monde à dire il faut
développer des énergies renouvelables
alors se passe sans problème
éolien solaire et toutes ces choses là
mais il ya une contrainte qui devrait
guider notre réflexion c'est que les les
la production d'énergie électrique
renouvelable n'est pas pilotable elle
dépend du soleil et du vent un peu
heureusement de l'hydroélectricité qui
elle est pilotable comme bahnou 12% donc
mai
à une production d'électricité non
pilotable il faut équilibrer par une
production d'électricité pilotable est
la seule production d'électricité
pilotable qui
puisse être proposé dans des proportions
suffisantes
c'est l'énergie nucléaire décarbonée
cette énergie nucléaire
elle dépend de décisions à prendre
aujourd'hui si l'on veut qu'elles
s'appliquent dans cinq ans on est en
plein dans la préoccupation du long
terme qui est la nôtre
or ces décisions ne sont pas prises et
elles sont urgentes
parce que comme vous le savez vous avez
étudié ça surabondamment toutes les
projections indiquent qu'on va se
trouver d'ici 25 à 30 ans peut-être à
peine un peu plus longtemps sur
prolonger la vie des centrales
nucléaires existantes qui pour la
plupart ont été inaugurés dans les
années 80 décision prise dans les années
70 inaugurée sous giscard décision une
tribulation dans les années 80 par
mitterrand ces deux îles sont des vous
savez des dizaines et donc si nous ne
faisons rien on va se trouver devant ce
que les spécialistes appellent en effet
falaise c'est à dire un effondrement
brutal de notre capacité à produire de
l'énergie
produire de l'électricité décarbonés par
le nucléaire
si nous n'avons pas pris les décisions
attend ça veut dire que nous allons être
obligés de remmettre des gaz à effet de
serre en créant des centrales au gaz au
charbon
tout ce que le pétrole tout ce que nous
savons est donc là il ya un énorme
travail à conduire ce qui veut dire
qu'il faut que nous acceptions de
regarder en face les données qui sont
des données de réalité de données
chiffrées et puis nous sommes passés
conformément au décret que vous avez lu
aux questions démographiques parce que
ça aussi ce sont des questions de long
terme pour signaler que la france qui
était jusqu'à maintenant le le premier
pays au monde le premier pays en europe
excusez moi dans pas là par le dynamisme
démographique se trouve aujourd'hui
devant un fléchissement est que comme
c'est pas du tout au contraire de ce que
dit un certain nombre de gens un
fléchissement conjoncturel mais un
fléchissement qui datent de 6 ou 7 ans
et je crois que les décisions qui ont
été prises sous le gouvernement
les gouvernements de françois hollande
concernant par exemple les allocations
familiales etc
on joue un rôle
mystérieux pas facile à décrire mais il
se trouve que c'est absolument
concomitant du fléchissement
alors cette réflexion sur sur la
démographie sur le dynamisme
démographique de la france sur le
dynamisme démographique de l'europe
le contraste est temps incroyable entre
les pays développés où la démographie
fléchi et de l'afghanistan à l'afrique
où la démographie est au contraire
extrêmement vigoureuse
certains affirment que la population
africaine va être multiplié par deux les
chercheurs disent que c'est ça c'est
certain
multiplié par deux à horizon de 25 ans
et peut-être par trois dans les 20
années suivantes et vous ne pouvez pas
avoir dans le monde et sur la planète
un déséquilibre aussi important entre
des zones qui sont des zones supposées
de prospérité et les zones de pauvreté
les zones de pauvreté ayant une
démographie vigoureuse
et explosive parfois et nos pays
développés étant en situation de
fléchissement démographique et tout cela
implique une réflexion sur sur le sur la
politique familiale en particulier
puisque tout le monde a remarqué depuis
longtemps que c'est évidemment la
situation faite aux mères de famille qui
commande en partie la démographie du
pays
la france a eu la démographie la plus
vigoureuse parce que c'était les femmes
françaises qui travaillaient le plus
donc la conciliation entre l'activité
professionnelle et le choix familial
d'avoir des enfants
ce qui veut dire plusieurs choses ce qui
veut dire l'accueil de l'enfant les
crèches les assistantes maternelles
l'effort pour favoriser là pour
faciliter la vie professionnelle en même
temps que la vie de mère de famille
la garantie qu'ils devraient être
apportées aux femmes que leur carrière
sera protégé
y compris si elles font le choix d'avoir
des enfants ce qui induit des
changements assez profonds dans
l'entreprise et dans l'esprit de
l'entreprise
et puis finalement le la clé
fondamentale c'est un certain optimisme
du pays parce que nous partageons une
vision optimiste de l'avenir ou est-ce
qu'au contraire nous sommes dans une
vision pessimiste et on voit que la
vision pessimiste signifie un
fléchissement de la démographie tout le
monde a les esprits simples pensait que
le confinement favoriserait la
procréation et qu'on allait avoir un
baby-boom duo premier confinement sont
aperçus que c'était exactement le
contraire que l'inquiétude sur la
situation du pays
induisent est au contraire une
une prudence une réticence et que au
contraire le choix d'avoir des enfants
quelle que soit la forme de la famille
du couple cia couple est au contraire
dépendante du facteur d'optimisme de la
société et donc et donc c'est sur ce lac
a porté le travail dont vous avez
entendu parler cette semaine qui a lui
aussi fait susciter des questions des
reportages sans l'ombre des
interventions diverses et variées et sur
lesquels je serai naturellement content
de répondre aussi sur quelques-uns de
ces sujets et d'autres
vous avez des vous avez des réflexions
on va avoir
les travaux qui viennent un travail sur
l'innovation en matière de santé on va
faire la cartographie des médicaments et
des commandes y procéder dispositifs
médicaux comme on dit aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui dépend
du reste du monde et qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être si nous sommes au niveau
puisque nous sommes au niveau
technologique pertinents qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être à nouveau produit chez
nous on va avoir
on va cartographier notre vulnérabilité
en matière de médicaments
ce travail a commencé on va s'occuper de
l'eau on va s'occuper de la reconquête
sous l'angle des secteurs que nous avons
déserté
on va essayer de repérer vos l'anneau
nos prochains travaux vous m'aviez
demandé ou fait seul dans votre
invitation de vous parler à un moment
des moyens du commissariat au plan des
moyens sont très simples même si vous ne
le croyez pas alors je vais quand même
le dire le commissariat au plan c'est
cet équivalent temps plein et demi voilà
sept équivalents temps plein quant au
commissaire il est bénévole
intégralement
il a choisi d'être bénévole
intégralement ni salaire ni indemnité ni
notes de frais dmir voyage ni
voiture ni chauffeur ni secrétariat
alors vous me direz que c'est que c'est
absurde à ces prêts ma femme aussi très
considéré que ce que vous auriez raison
mais j'ai fait ce choix pour une raison
très précise c'est que l'époque nous
vivons est tellement focalisés sur les
privilèges les avantages les les
questions de
des facilités qui m'a semblé que si je
faisais un autre choix et on l'a vu pour
d'autres au commissaire dans d'autres
fonctions
si je faisais un autre choix le la forme
de cette question des moyens empêcherait
d'entendre le chant très chaud il ya
même des collègues avenant qui m'ont
fait dès qu'ils ont fait des questions
écrites par s'émouvoir de de ses moyens
de cette gabegie
c'est plus facile pour moi de répondre
en répondant 0 voilà le voilà les
questions que l'introduction que je
voulais faire autour de 7 de ce constat
que nous faisons le même métier est
alors un mot peut-être sur la manière de
procéder
on a observé depuis très longtemps que
les rapports étaient innombrables le
nombre de d'institutions qui produisent
des rapports documenté
sérieux sur tous les sujets c'est foison
simplement on n'en fait jamais rien les
commissions des assemblées
le conseil économique et social les
think tanks divers et variés tout cela
produit des sommes or c'est une mine
abandonnée ce team nomine qui n'est pas
mise en exploitation et nous avons fait
le choix de les mettre en exploitation
alors naturellement je dispose en tant
que de besoin de francs stratégie et des
administrations de l'état
mais il se trouve que je pense que le la
la réflexion et la capacité à dégager
une ligne stratégique sur tous les
sujets à partir des faits quand ils sont
pas contestables me paraît une démarche
plus politique et plus forte
à condition qu'on soit capable de la
relayer auprès de l'opinion et vous avez
vu ce qu'il en était donc comme vous
l'avez souligné
nous sommes en contact régulier avec les
commissions de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
et je vais devant le conseil économique
et social dans sa formule précédente et
je vais y retourner dans sa forme une
nouvelle pour partager avec eux la
réflexion sur ces sujets le en un mot et
au moment de du dévoilement des lignes
directrices de nos rapports et de la
suite parce qu'il y aura il faut qu'il y
ait un aval voilà comment nous
nous travaillons et c'est pour nous très
très gratifiant de de conduire cette
réflexion-là et de la partager jeu je
rapporte au président de la république
que c'est au président de la république
que je soumets des désorientations que
nous avons définies vous savez tous il y
avait un verre d'eau je serai le plus
heureux des hommes tout de suite
un grand merci en tout cas monsieur
commissaire pour pour ces propos qui qui
démontre le lien qui lie à entre vous
l'avez souligné nos travaux et la
réflexion que vous avez conduite et que
vous continuez à conduire peut-être pour
lancer l'échangé et le débat vous poser
une question qui reprend un petit peu
votre propos introductif peut-être un
peu une question que je qualifierais de
philosophique nous avions ici même il y
a quelques mois
l'occasion de recevoir erik orsenna et
s'agissant de ce que vous évoquiez sur
la culture de l'instant de l'immédiateté
qui a des conséquences sur en termes
d'actions publiques de prise de décision
erik orsenna nous disait il faut que
nous réapprenions le temps long
réapprendre le temps long pour aussi
permettre d'avoir cette prise de recul
nécessaire en matière d'action publique
pour mieux éclairer nos choix à l'avenir
et la première question que je
souhaitais vous posez c'est est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas finalement dans la
planification dans le plan une capacité
à réapprendre ce temps long dans la
mesure où ce qui est anxiogène et vous
l'a évoqué notamment avec la crise
sanitaire
à travers de ce qu'ont pu vivre vont
parler de la démographie nos concitoyens
et ce caractère anxiogène de cette crise
qui finalement on n'invite pas au temps
long et donc est ce que la planification
c'est pas aussi une façon de donner à
voir à nos concitoyens ce qu'il y a à
horizon 10 20 30 ans et peut-être
quelque part à les rassurer sur leur
avenir sur ce qui les attend et de vivre
quelque chose qui est moins anxiogène à
monsieur le président c'est exactement à
ça que ça sert c'est exactement ça c'est
exactement ça parce que vous soulignez à
très juste titre que habituellement les
gouvernants et nos concitoyens
considèrent le temps long comme
inquiétant ils voient des dérives pour
pas dire des dérivés de de la situation
actuelle comme une menace
moi je considère que la préoccupation du
temps long au contrat doit être
rassurante
c'est par là le président de la
république 2
répète à l'envi que le problème de notre
pays de notre société s'est retrouvé le
contrôle on retrouve pas on ne peut pas
retrouver le contrôle si on se focalise
sur le lendemain sur l'immédiat le
contrôle ça suppose qu'on identifie les
problèmes les difficultés de l'avenir et
qu'on se propose une stratégie pour y
répondre
pas besoin d'insister auprès de vous sur
le fait que les questions stratégiques
sont pour moi des questions vitales
quels moyens quels capacités qu'elle sur
quel levier pouvons nous appuyer pour
que l'avenir soit le meilleur possible
encore une fois la question énergétique
par exemple suppose entre le délai
d'étude le délai de réalisation suppose
20 à 25 ans ce qui veut dire que si on
ne prend pas les décisions qui
s'imposent
d après 2022 vous comprenez que j'ai peu
d'espoir qu'on les prenne avant 2022
c'est pas pourquoi cette date me paraît
une date peu propice mais je pense que
le débat de l'élection présidentielle
doit porter en particulier sur les
décisions qu'on doit prendre sur ces
sujets là et que pour une forme les élus
de pas
et bien c'est maintenant qu'il faut
qu'on prenne des décisions nécessaires
en danse posant des questions qui sont
des questions pour moi traumatisante
comment la france at-elle perdu un
certain nombre de ses capacités et de
ses compétences technologiques en
matière d'énergie par exemple on a les
hommes au fil de l'eau on a laissé
s'échapper ce qui était notre parmi nos
biens les plus précieux c'est pas le
seul secteur mais c'est le secteur le
plus significatif encore une fois c'est
par dizaines qu'on a construit des
réacteurs nucléaires dans les années
la fin des années 70 c'est dans les
années 80 de même que vous avez sur vos
murs
des constructions c'est quoi cette année
airbus remarquable je reviens à
l'instant sur cette idée de reconquête
et quand on prend
l'étude de notre déficit du commerce
extérieur
alors on s'aperçoit qu'il y à des
productions qui sont pas notre
disposition
hier nous discutions ensemble le café
pense est un déficit qui est contraint
par les conditions climatiques agricoles
etc
mais nous avons 30 milliards je crois de
déficit en équipements de la maison
quand on est capable de produire des
satellites des fusées des avions parmi
les meilleurs du monde des des voitures
des sous marins nucléaires un sous marin
nucléaire c'est dans un tube 200 m une
ville une base de lancement de fusées et
une usine de production d'électricité
nucléaire dans un tube
quand on est capable de faire ça quand
on maîtrise était quand on est un des
meilleurs pays du monde sur les
questions d'algorithmes
comment est ce que on est exclu de
production entière qui sont des
productions
comment on peut dire plus plus basiques
quand on sait faire les meilleurs
turbines du monde chez moi
comment comment se fait-il qu'on conçoit
pas capable de faire une machine à laver
ces questions qui ont l'air rétrogrades
pour ne pas dire réactionnaire aux yeux
de certains qui qui ont renoncé depuis
très longtemps qui ont conseillé quand
renault depuis tellement longtemps à ces
choses là sont pour moi des questions
extrêmement préoccupante et on va
essayer de les étudier pour produire des
faits pour pour mettre en évidence des
faits merci j'ai une série de cinq
questions dont j'ai passé la parole à
nos collègues dans les invitant
peut-être à la la concision pour que le
commissaire puisse ceci est un message
subliminal pour moi de j'essaie de
traduire en français ce que martèlent
que je très innovant le coup mais
comment on peut être très prolixe
monsieur le commissaire voilà c'était
plutôt à l'endroit de l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui j'en suis sûr ont beaucoup
de sujets évoqués avec vous j'ai passé
tout d'abord la parole à cécile
cukierman merci merci le haut
commissaire pour cette présentation je
crois qu'au delà de la question de la
sémantique cela démontre en tout cas que
oui il ya besoin de planifier
d'anticiper chacun utilisera les termes
et les références qu'il souhaite
mais de la même façon vous l'avez montré
à travers l'exemple l'énergie le pays
pour dans 20 30 ans ne se construira pas
la veille de ses 20 30 ans et bien
évidemment cela doit s'organiser et
réfléchie et parfois ça en respectant le
temps démocratique
en tout cas savoir le dépasse et ne pas
rester contraint par celui ci qui bien
évidemment est un formidable tant
d'énergie citoyenne mais qui ne doit pas
être me permettra l'expression un
empêcheur de tourner en rond
deux remarques sur ce que vous avez
évoquées à savoir sur les secteurs de
production ouvrira pas ici un débat
politique sur le pourquoi nous en sommes
là dans notre pays
la question est donc toujours en arriver
là on peut y avoir tout de même
regretter que c'est effectivement une
crise sanitaire qui nous fait démontré à
grande échelle sur plusieurs secteurs
le retard et les difficultés de notre
pays dans ce sens mais sachons justement
en inspirer vous avez parlé de l'énergie
sachons anticipé aujourd'hui sur ce
qu'elle sera demain est ce que oui ou
non nous laissons partir les derniers
fleurons de notre pays qui permettent
j'ai aucun souci sur la diversité de la
production énergétique mais qui
permettent en tout cas aujourd'hui de
s'enorgueillir de pouvoir produire des
panneaux photovoltaïques en france sans
être forcément dépendant de la chine
si on continue de voir certaines
entreprises fermées les fours de
silicium et les entreprises qui
produisent les pannes ou être en
difficulté ce n'est pas à 20 30 ans que
l'on produiront plus
c'est à quelques mois voire quelques
années donc comment est ce qu un moment
donné nos politiques nos politiques je
vis dans
vers cités sont réellement des
accompagnateurs de des différents
secteurs de production et sur la
question énergétique je voulais revenir
parce que bien évidemment il aura besoin
d électrifier a évoqué les voitures on
pourrait commencer d'abord par les
chemins de fer encore un certain nombre
de new line ne sont pas électrifiées et
on gagnerait la très fortement y compris
en matière environnementale on se doit
je crois aussi de réfléchir aujourd'hui
non pas dans une vision de décroissance
mais sur la question du logement nous
pouvons tout à fait imaginer que dans 20
30 ans laura des logements qui seront
moins consommateurs d'énergie avec un
confort meilleur cependant pour celles
et ceux qui habitent la question n'est
bien évidemment pas de revenir à la
chandelle pour autant donc voilà je
voulais revenir sur ça parce que willy a
besoin de décider aujourd'hui de des
productions énergétiques mais je crois
qu'il ya besoin de décider aujourd'hui
d'investir dans la recherche
je vais prendre un exemple du logement
et c'est vrai pour toutes les chaînes
industrielles d'ailleurs de réfléchir
aux six années d évolution qui peuvent
être moins consommatrices d'une énergie
aussi répondre de façon croisée genre
évident à cenon le défi je finirai sur
la question de la natalité
je partage ça vient discours de toute
façon état d'esprit en tout cas
optimiste parce que c'est pas être
qu'une question discours que l'on en
croit et que m'ont incité à la natalité
peut-être un discours politique d'air
qui pendant de nombreuses années a
tellement dit que certains
s'enrichissent avec les allocations
familiales
on prend conscience qu'en fait je
faisais moi mais avoir des enfants ça a
un coût ça a un coût et vous l'avez dit
la réduction du choix qui a été fait
sous quinquennat précédent de remettre
en cause l'universalisme des allocations
familiales est une erreur et une erreur
parce qu'il attaque tout premier lieu et
classe moyenne va le dire comme ça
qui sont également génératrice de
dépenses dès lors qu'elles ont des
familles avec plusieurs enfants mais ça
a un coût aujourd'hui encore et au delà
de la question des allocations
familiales
sur quelle politique lui de la petite
enfance moi je suis frappé aujourd'hui
dans un certain nombre de grandes villes
de jeunes couples où effectivement la
question du 2eme 3eme enfant est posée
de couples 1-2 des couple les deux
personnes qui travaillent on va prendre
et où effectivement la garde d'enfant
devient un surcoûts exorbitants parfois
pour ne pas dire ou alors si les faits
il les fait au détriment d'autres choses
qui semblent indispensables parce que
oui le letton évolué et on souhaite pour
ces enfants qui puisse faire une
activité sportive culturelle et c'est à
faire des études et donc bien évidemment
quand on souhaite que ses enfants face à
ces études cela pose aussi à une plus
18-20 là est la question de leur
financement dont j'ai envie de vous dire
voilà sur le constat que vous faites en
matière de natalité qu'elle aussi
réflexion qui se donnerait friction un
fer et est proposé
dès aujourd'hui et pendant quelques
années certainement leurs réalisations
sur ces problématiques je crois à la
fois de de garde d'enfants pour la
partie petite enfance mais aussi sur
l'accompagnement des coûts passé un
certain âge pour permettre cette
poursuite d'études et ainsi espère en
tout cas que ces enfants vivent mieux
que soi même ce qui est aussi un des
gages de l'optimisme dans une politique
nataliste bas prix merci je passe la
parole à eric bocquet qui est en visio
oui bonjour je vais donc chez le haut
commissaire le support ses propos
introductifs une question très simple
vous avez évoqué le nécessaire conquête
dont matière économique notamment
mais qu'elle assimile briennon dans
cette perspective à 15 20 ou 30 ans
parce que j'ai le sentiment que vous
avez hésité à utiliser le mot ultra
libéralisme qui est peut-être excessif
mais quand même je pense que cette
pandémie
c'est un peu l'aboutissement de quatre
décennies
moi je repense à cette formule leur égal
lors de son discours inaugural en 80 il
te disait venez là n'est pas la solution
l'état scène problème et je pense que
les chalumeaux dans un véhicule avec ce
dogme l'un avec toutes les conséquences
concrètes en matière de choix politiques
et économiques privatisation des
régulations libye les forces du marché
la main invisible du marché donc de
moins en moins d'état qu'on a voulu qu
chine et à ses fonctions régaliennes
justice police diplomatie mais rien à
faire dans l'économie or là on sent le
redécouvrir avec force la nécessité d'
année là loin de moi et tout l'état en
est revenu tout cela c'est évident mais
l'état un rôle essentiel si l'état
n'avait pas été là effectivement il ya
un an pour apporter son soutien ces
aides financières sa capacité à
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
avec une aisance absolument remarquable
il bientôt négatif
bon
et un dans son rôle de pilote alors quel
rôle vous achèteriez vous allaitez
reconquête de pilotage de l'état
stratège par les services au public par
son implication dans les grandes
entreprises
face à tant voulu marchandises et à des
fins d'efficacité supérieur lundi jette
on voit là est ce qu'on n'est pas à la
fin de la guerre
merci merci chez reebok et vanina paolig
agen bonjour monsieur le président
monsieur le haut commissaire merci
beaucoup de nous avoir exposé cet esprit
de reconquête qui qui vous anime
j'aurai deux bref question une
philosophique sur ce temps long comment
peut-on faire pour que ces réflexions et
c'est perspective perspectives d'action
sur le temps l'on puisse survivre en
fait aux mouvements démocratiques bien
nécessaire et au changement de majorité
successifs parce que je pense que c'est
une faiblesse pour notre pays
vous évoquez la chine on peut penser
aussi à taiwan qui a décidé il ya 20 ans
d'être le champion du microprocesseur
donc on voit bien que tout où tous les
pays même tout petit qui veulent se
poser en leader mondiaux sur des
verticales industriels ou technologiques
prennent ces décisions effectivement
longtemps la vence mais surtout garde ce
cap
moi mon problème quand j'observe mon
pays sur le temps long c'est que le cap
on ne garde jamais et vous faisiez un
constat est me semble-t-il ça continue
jugé jeu crainte de vous dire que ça
continue c'est à dire qu'en fait on on
est une espèce de deux pathologies sui
generis en france parce qu'on a des
inventeurs géniaux on a des innovations
génial l'ancêtre de l'internet c'est
nous la batterie lithium-ion est né sur
une paillasse du cnrs la rn
sage et c'est français pourquoi pourquoi
n'avons nous pas d'acteur leader ou un
euro bien sûr ces secteurs on a un
problème intermédiaire on a un problème
de financement du temps intermédiaire
entre ces innovations qui émerge est le
temps où elle arrive sur le marché
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui moi je vois
des entreprises
l'ordinateur quantique peut être
français il ne sera pas français je
pense parce qu'on n'a pas de fonds
d'investissement même l'européen qui est
des tailles et des poches suffisamment
profondes pour financer ce genre
d'innovation l'amorçage sur une telle
innovation c'est plus de 20 millions
d'euros dès la deuxième année ses 80
millions pourquoi parce qu'il faut aller
débaucher des ingénieurs à standford om
haïti etc et que c'est cette
intelligence collective humaine qui va
faire qu'on va pouvoir développer plus
vite ce type d'innovation il ya les
mêmes sujets sur le stockage de
l'énergie
on a des entreprises de haute
technologie qui sont extraordinaires
qu'on essaie de soutenir jeu de bpi fait
son boulot etc
on a un problème d'échelle et on peut
pas tout embrasser parce que qui trop
embrasse mal étreint donc y'a un moment
il faut faire des choix il faut faire
des choix c'est la stratégie que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure on pourra pas
être bon partout mais on a des idées des
pôles d'excellence dans de nombreux
domaines donc j'espère qu'on va faire
un travail d'amaigrissement en fait et
ensuite qu'on va mettre vraiment le
paquet je parle très vulgairement sur
les trois quatre secteurs qu'on va avoir
identifié les 10-15 innovation qu'on va
estimer pouvoir être des innovations de
rupture technologique mais qui va
falloir soutenir pendant 10 ans 15 ans
20 ans avant qu'elle ne soit mature pour
disrupt et le marché merci merci
philippe dominati
mais c'est notre mission mais le
président remercie pour ce jeune
échanges intéressants
perrine moquer un peu comme à son
habitude a mis le ce parce que je
reprendrai les termes de ce qui m'a
choquée moi c'est effectivement le fait
que vous ayez peut-être poser les
problèmes en disant que c'était à cause
de l'ultralibéralisme alors que moi j'ai
plutôt tendance à français que l'état
c'est le problème est dans cette crise
on l'a très bien démontré parce que les
pays de tendance libérale dans un
premier temps pris un temps de retard
on nous mêmes et puis par la suite elle
non seulement combler ce retard mais
maintenant ils sont en avance dans la
réaction vis-à-vis de la crise sanitaire
et nous ne l'avons plutôt le sentiment
moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que les
français attend tout de l'état je dirais
presque du matin leurs événements
jusqu'au soir les habitués à une sorte
de sécurité d'assurance ou ris et
finalement les à boire s'occuper de tout
lorsque vous évoquez le secteur de l'ena
l'énergie c'est l'état depuis 40 ans en
réalité les audiences c'est l'état le
nucléaire c'est l'état et les
interrogations niche bouger c'est l'état
les chantiers de l'atlantique c'est
l'état et pourtant on est obligé de les
vendre donc de trouver des partenariats
aux italiens dans ce que les coréens
n'avaient cheveux les ex-fumeurs le mot
ventes de renault ont deux jours soit un
chien soit interdisant le contrat chien
c'est encore l'état en réalité l'état se
mêle de nos entreprises en permanence et
ce n'est pas l'intérêt des entreprises
de définir l'intérêt général c'est parce
que le décideur qui pourrait aussi bien
utiliser le secteur public que le
secteur privé en ré noté compte
essentiellement intervenir
pratiquement dans le monde de l'économie
en permanence mais souvent avec un grand
retard avec des contraintes et puis
surtout une fiscalité en partie
pénalisante sont à crise sanitaire en
réaliser tout le secteur hospitalier
privé negra n'a presque pas été
sollicités et donc c'est quand même
quelque chose de frappant dans tous les
départements
on n'est que contacter concernés par le
secteur privé en disant moi ça fait un
an que je regarde souvent du devoir
j'attends peut-être un jour et vincent
se pressent ce niveau je suis obligé de
prendre même patient puis de l'aider
comment des forêts noté ça ne fonctionne
pas lorsqu'on prend la poche ou amazon
dans le confinement
bien heureusement qu'un mason était là
malheureusement c'est né d'une société
de services aucune société européenne
était en mesure de faire cette société
de services tandis que la poste en
réalité celle efficient on entend
régulièrement de dire au nom de la
ruralité
il faut ne repasse moi je suis prêt à
leur poste s'ils fonctionnent mais comme
il fonctionne pas la plupart étant qu'on
a eu l'idée résonne alors moi je retiens
que en réalité le commissariat au plan
très souvent il ne peut fonctionner que
s'il a une écoute et que je suis l'aîné
coupe de la part de l'administration ont
du pouvoir en place et donc c'est très
difficile effectivement pour une
instance tel que vous l'avez défini
d'avoir cette force d'une crédibilité
puisque si on part du principe que
l'état est trop présent dans l'économie
française est bien mis devant vous
risquez d'être écoutés mais bien des cas
et c'est davantage que vous avez c'est
que vous êtes totalement indépendant de
vérifier moi je suis venu vite votre
femme
je trouve qu'en termes de crédibilité
que vous aurez dû prendre par exemple
10% ou un quart des moyens qui avait été
un kangourou haut commissaire au plan la
pauvreté elle sur l'éternité à retenir
si par exemple que j'aurais eu quelques
moyens et là vous aurez été entendu et
donc il faut cette crédibilité vis-à-vis
de l'état ou de l'administration ont
peut-être commencer par corriger tous
les défauts que nous ont procuré dans la
société française
un étrange qui est quand même ultra
jacomin et qui par son organisation
administrative donne quand même un
certain nombre de sièges de siècle on va
pas parler du millefeuille administratif
de la dilution des responsabilités à
tous les niveaux ça dans une entreprise
moderne c'est n'existe aucune existence
d'un autre état
c'est sur ces sujets là que moi
j'aimerais que les missions que vous
avez évidemment importante pour le temps
puisse se focaliser un petit peu merci
merci christine lagarde
oui merci monsieur le président
vos propos sur la démographie ont été
relayés dans la presse qui a plutôt axé
sur les constats et les préconisations
que vous faites en matière d'immigration
et sur le fait qu'il ne faut pas dire
non à l'immigration si on veut pouvoir
continuer à faire rien que le système d'
équilibre de nos retraites
moi j'aurais plutôt voulu vous entendre
sur les propositions que vous faites
pour relancer la politique familiale en
france est un peu dans l'est dans la
suite des propos de cécile kerman et il
ya quelque chose qui me frappe dans le
système actuel
au delà des allocations familiales c'est
que notre système considère qu'un enfant
jusqu'à 5 ans et 364 jours ne peut pas
garder seul et bénéficier des familles
toutes les familles disent peiner fisea
de dispositif de crédit d'impôt
le jour il a 6 ans et un jour il devient
autonome peut rentrer seule celle mis
fin en tout cas il n'y a plus aucune
aide pour la garde d'enfants et je pense
que cet élément au delà même de et là ça
touche toutes les familles il vraiment
quelque chose qui me semble enfin c'est
frappant donc est-ce que c'est qu'il
faudrait pas agir là dessus pour
justement favoriser c'est à dire qu'on
se focalise sur le très jeune enfant
la crèche mais on ne va pas au delà et
un enfant je suis désolé ma 6 ans et un
jour il est pas autonome
c'était une remarque et vous avez
peut-être d'autres propositions bernard
fialaire bernard fialaire donc le rhône
groupe rdse j'ai deux questions la
première pour reprendre certains de vos
propos aussi récent sur
le système de protection sociale on sait
bien quand même que le budget de la
protection sociale est supérieur à celui
de l'état
on doit passer d'un système bismarckien
vers un système de beveridge on sent
bien que le grand projet du conseil
national de la résistance s'est fait
dans une période où pouvoir la retraite
à 65 ans une espérance de vie à 64 ans
et demi où on commence à travailler à 14
ans et où il y avait le plein emploi et
qu'aujourd'hui le système peut plus
fonctionner alors moi j'ai beaucoup de
regrets sur finalement le premier pas
avait été fait avec le premier point de
cg de rocard et j'ai beaucoup de regrets
la chronologie des mesures du président
macron qui en augmentant d'abord la csg
avant les autres les gens a quand même
psychologiquement mis un gros frein sur
ce glissement faudra bien qu'un jour la
santé soit et toute la protection
sociale soient prises par l'ensemble des
ressources surtout celles qui sont les
plus importantes et pas simplement
pénaliser le travail dont on sait que
quand vous dites que le travail c
la recherche c'est la richesse de notre
pays et c'est ce qui est le plus taxé
donc ça c'est ma première question
la deuxième c'est une réflexion qui va
un peu à l'encontre de ce que vous aviez
dit qu'ils étaient portés par même le
sénateur lafitte ans nos prédécesseurs
sur le fait qu'il disait il faut plutôt
délocaliser pour produire là où il ya de
la main d'oeuvre plutôt continué enfin
moi je le vois sur mon territoire on a
énormément de fonderie si demain on crée
encore des emplois et elle se développe
on est obligé d'aller chercher de
l'immigration turque ou du maghreb pour
pour travailler c'est à dire que
certaines productions ne sont fait
qu'avec des travailleurs ligne sauf
lorsque les technologies sont
suffisamment avancé qu'à ce moment là on
est dans la recherche développement et
il les emplois plus propres ingénieurs
mais sinon on fait et est ce que c'est
un progrès de l'humanité que d'aller
déplacer des populations pour venir
travailler avec tous les problèmes qui
en vendent de culture d'acceptation des
choses comme ça et puis de toute petite
dernière réflexion aussi sur sur la
baisse de la natalité on parle d elle
est aussi un des facteurs qui intervient
beaucoup c'est quand même le coût du
logement
parce que vous augmentez une famille
vous avez besoin d'agrandir et on est
dans un pays où c'est mon avis presque
disproportionné le coup
l'habitat dans notre pays et ça aussi
c'est un frein général d'ailleurs sur
dans différents propos
enfin je salue la vertu de votre
bénévolat et je vous conseillerais pas
d'être financées par du privé pour que
l'état se mêle pas trop de vos affaires
je le reconnais merci deux dernières
interventions
julien bargeton bonjour à toutes et à
tous bonjour mais le haut commissaire je
vais revenir donc demeurer idéologique
nous avons eu quelques questions la
ville
comment vous voyez l'impact des
transitions en cours et notamment sur
les chiffres pour vous pas un décret
choix génération pense bien sûr à
l'urgence écologique la transition
écologique
je pense évidemment la transition
numérique on a beaucoup d'études sur le
temps passé hier les écrans
quel va être selon vous l'impact de ce
temps assez bien les écrans par les
jeunes notamment puisque c'est un sujet
parfois de préoccupation de régulation
mais pas seulement deux changements à
lui monde est de même sur les
transitions démocratiques
on voit bien que pour les jeunes
générations le vote ne puisse pas la
respiration démocratique souhaitée
finalement il y avait d'autres façons de
porter des combats on a tout ce débat
d'ailleurs avec la conférence citoyenne
sur le climat au référendum utilisation
aussi du numérique pour voter dans
certains pays comme en estonie et sait
comment vous voyez sur le temps long la
différence foulon entre générations sur
ces grandes transition écologique
numérique et démocratique pour ne citer
que ces trois là
merci novembre céline boulay speroni
plus raccord une dernière question que
c'est rajouter de sylvie vermeillet
merci monsieur le président monsieur
émissaire croissance rapide
la première est qu'il joue
la première condition par les politiques
en matière de santé
donc est ce qu'il faut le penser c'est
politique en intégrant le futur crise
sanitaire et notamment les moyens et je
pensais au nombre de lits de réanimation
tandis que il faut pas forcément les
augmenter énormément pour du beurre
puisque cette crise ayant été
exceptionnelle viendra pas forcément
d'autres vous avez vous avez parlé du
fait même cette prise avait révélé des
crises structurelles et notamment dans
une dépendance
la deuxième question comment voyez vous
évoluer la famille et notamment
l'éducation à 20 ou 25 ans lorsque les
réseaux sociaux prennent souvent sur
l'éducation elle ça rejoint place se
disait alain sans julien bargeton et
enfin troisième manche est ce que la
politique définitivement l'ennemi d'une
vision pleinement profité du sens
notamment la gestion du quinquennat
puisqu'on a vu que dès lors que à un
café n'a été percutée par une crise
endogène c'est le cas du quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy par exemple avec la
crise des subprimes et celui ci avec la
crise du coc vide
est ce que il est possible pour un
président de la république d'avoir une
question de mon thème est engagé une
véritable vision prospective dans un
temps politique qui est extrêmement
contraint voilà je vous remercie
merci et enfin pour conclure cette série
d'interventions de questions sylvie
vermeillet oui bonjour monsieur
président j'en ai su le haut commissaire
et merci pour votre exposé très très
intéressant
j'ai deux questions rapides très
différentes la première évidemment vous
exposez l'intérêt
la souveraineté nationale alors un petit
peu à l'opposé
j'aimerais que vous rognez un peu sur le
degré de menace que représente pour les
pays étrangers en la rencontrant bien
l'intérêt de cette souveraineté mais
qu'est ce que la crise a révélé de deux
particulièrement menaçant vis-à-vis de
pays comme la chine ou les états unis
vous nous avez pas trop parler de ce
contexte international et les rapports
de force qui changent qu'est ma deuxième
question porte sur l'arrêt de la gestion
de l'eau vous l'avez à peine évoquée il
me semble que c'est un enjeu absolument
majeur
est ce que l'état va prendre toute sa
place et va impulser une véritable
politique de gestion de l'eau dans notre
pays
il me semble que en ce moment ce sont
plutôt des initiatives locales
territoriales qui sont prises et à
l'évidence il faut que ce soit l'état
qui impulsent une organisation nationale
sans même parler
ce que la crise sanitaire a révélé des
besoins d'organisation particuliers
notamment avec l'agencé régionale de
santé si demain nous avions une
pollution de l'eau je ne pense pas que
l'agente de l'eau soit en mesure de nous
permettre de répondre à la crise voilà
mais d'une façon très 39 transversale la
gestion de l'eau le drainage du stockage
ça est ce que l'état va prendre toute sa
place et son degré l'impulsion sur cette
politique merci merci après ce
foisonnement de questions de réflexion
de positionnement je vous cède à nouveau
monsieur le commissaire je vais répondre
chronologiquement jeu j'aurais pu
rassembler des questions mais je veux
je me suivre l'ordre des prises de
parole cécile kuperman sur les
technologies en matière d'énergies
renouvelables
moi je crois que nous avons en effet une
carte à jouer je vais reprendre
exactement ce que vous avez évoqué sur
les panneaux photovoltaïques
premièrement la question des panneaux
photovoltaïques c'est la question des
cellules photovoltaïques et la question
des cellules photovoltaïques c'est la
question de la fusion du silicium de
l'énergie y mange pas des torches à
plasma qu'il faut pour faire fondre le
silicium pour produire créer des
cellules photovoltaïques
si l'énergie que vous utilisez pour
faire pour obtenir la fusion du silicium
études énergies carbonées
alors vous avez évidemment un bilan
carbone qui est amoindrie des années de
production sont nécessaires pour
rééquilibrer alors j'ai lu tous les
chiffres donc mais jancovici venu devant
vous je crois en parler jean marc
jancovici et je partage ce sentiment
en revanche nous français nous pouvons
obtenir des cellules photovoltaïques
performantes dont nous pouvons garantir
que l'utilisation d'électricité pour
obtenir la fusion du silicium et des
abonnés et c'est une réflexion qui ce
qui s'applique aux cellules
photovoltaïques mais qui s'applique
on est en train de travailler sur ce
sujet à une grande partie des industries
de production
le jour on considérera que l'élément de
la production d'énergie nécessaire doit
être décarbonés
alors nous deviendrons attrayant pour un
grand nombre de producteurs à la
recherche des standards qui sont ceux de
l'abaissement des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre et à l'échelle de la
france a peut être extrêmement
intéressant de même que la recherche est
intéressante il se trouve que nous avons
à pau des qui est une ville dans
l'université spécialisée dans
particulier dans les questions
énergétiques qui est labellisé is it sur
ces questions là c'est une des huit
universités françaises labellisées is it
sur ces questions là nous avons des
laboratoires qui travaillent sur les
cellules faux sur les les panneaux
photovoltaïques de la génération
ultérieure que d'appel organique et qui
eux et dont le bilan carbone est
absolument négligeable il faut sept
jours je crois de production pour
rembourser le bilan carbone de même si
c'était un mois
il y aurait pas de problème et l'
avantage de ces panneaux c'est qu'ils
peuvent être aussi placé à l'ombre ce
qui veut dire que sur les façades des
maisons on pourrait avoir des surfaces
de production d'électricité
photovoltaïque alors le rendement au m²
de panneaux n'est pas le même ça doit
être aujourd'hui un facteur 3 à peu près
mais si le coot de l'équipement et la
surface est plus grande alors on arrive
à meyer et puis ça peut être doublée
d'isolde isolation des maisons comme
vous l'avez a trait à très juste titre
indiqué donc le la capacité de
production des panneaux photovoltaïques
dans une démarche qui est une démarche
décarbonée c'est un grand atout de notre
pays et on pourrait imaginer que ce soit
à proximité de réacteurs de centrales
complices
obtenir cette production vous dites
schumann faire il va falloir électrifié
on peut aussi servir de l'hydrogène vous
savez qu alstom est en train de préparer
un train pardon je vous donne acte leu
leu
le responsable de la principale
collectivité du pot canfranc peut
absolument vous donner raison sur ce
sujet donc donc on en parlera belge vous
dire simplement que les technologies on
ne doit pas se limiter
devant les mutations technologiques
possibles
doit on voit les intégrer à la réflexion
stratégique
enfin sur l'universalisme des
allocations familiales je ne peux que
vous donnez raison je partage absolument
votre sentiment
alors il ya un point qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est pas si je les dis qu'il faut
avoir en tête quand on parle de
démographie il ya beaucoup d'éléments
qui sont inquiétants qui vont plutôt
dans le sens d'une affaiblissement d'un
fléchissement
il ya un élément positif c'est que quand
on conduit une enquête auprès des auprès
des parents et auprès des des mères de
famille dont on conduit une enquête pour
leur demander combien d'enfants il
voudrait la réponse est un enfant de
plus que le nombre
de celui qu'ils ont ce cadre on en
voudrait deux ceux qui en ont deux ans
voudrait 3 et on a des calages ainsi
entre le souhait et la réalité et vous
avez tous insisté sur la petite enfance
l'accompagnement le le le les aides à
l'enfance et des êtres ça minable je
crois que la clé est là mais elle est
d'abord dans l'optimisme du pays dans la
capacité de retrouver une vision qui
soit une vision assumer optimiste du
pays on y reviendra dans une seconde
alors on a eu une discussion très
intéressante sur le rôle de l'état et de
manière totalement inattendue eric bloch
et philippe dominati n'étaient pas du
même avis et donc et donc ça m'a ça m'a
rappelé des des jours plus anciens et
moi je crois que vous avez tous les deux
raison et ça n'est pas pour faire du ça
n'est pas pour faire du en même temps je
vais essayer de le prouver je
1 est ce que l'état marche bien
aujourd'hui la réponse est non à mes
yeux non autrement on aurait absolument
pas les résultats qu'on a obtenus le
l'espèce de de dérive
j'ai dit l'état a dérivé en
administration et l'administration
bureaucratie je suis frappé de voir ça
et je pense que quand le président de la
république se bat parce que ils se sur
ce sujet il se marre je veux dire il
n'obtient des décisions qu'au terme de
bataille y compris internes au sein de
l'état qui sont pas négligeables qui ne
sont pas faciles
c'est un engagement assidu de sa part
l'état aujourd'hui on le voit dans les
résultats n'a pas apporté à la france
les résultats qu'on était en droit
d'espérer
parce que il ya une dérive d esprit et
je soutiens que la réforme de l'état est
bien venue de ce point de vue là il ya
une dérive de l'esprit des esprits
l'état c'est spécial spécialisée dans la
production de normes dans le contrôle et
dans la sanction mais il fait pas son
travail qu'est le travail de soutien à
la société de soutien aux initiatives de
soutien aux entreprises d'indulgence
lorsque
elles ont mis le pied sur la ligne de
touche
dieu sait qu'on en a parlé de la
deuxième chance de la troisième chance
de s'est pas fait du tout le le
caractère de perpétuels production
normes être normative de de l'état est
de mon point de vue quelque chose qui
freine les initiatives de suffit de voir
combien de temps il faut en france pour
obtenir une autorisation pour un
établissement classé il faut entre 18 et
24 mois alors que chez tous nos voisins
il faut six mois je sais pas des
chiffres en l'air que je dois de ces le
c'est là c'est la réalité des choses est
donc cet état là je donne sur ce point
raison à philippe dominati
il n'est pas en soutien comme il devrait
l'être
des initiatives des inventions de la
créativité de la société française en
revanche je suis absolument acquis à
l'idée que l'état pourrait avoir un
autre rôle et là je suis plutôt beau et
east bocchetti stucker magnin enfin tout
ce que
et ça surprendra sans doute mais le
parce que je pense que l'état pourrait
être stratège et fédérateur il pourrait
rassembler les capacités de la société
française d'entreprises privées et de
grandes entreprises privées pour caen se
fixent ensemble des buts à atteindre et
sur ce point je suis vraiment désaccord
avec philippe dominati
quand il dit ce n'est pas le rôle des
entreprises de s'inscrire dans l'intérêt
général
bah si c'est le rôle des entreprises
aussi c'est le rôle des citoyens
c'est le rôle des entreprises encore
faut-il encore faut-il que nous ayons la
volonté de définir un intérêt général
et ça c'est le rôle de l'état stratège
et fédérateur et si on avait rempli ce
rôle
alors j'ai été très intéressé par
l'intervention de madame paoli cage un
seul avait rempli ce rôle
alors internet n'aurait pas filer nous
l'avons inventé sont des français qui
ont tout inventé internet et on peut
faire le entre nous je sais que c'est ça
suscite des sarcasmes
le minitel c'était génial on a créé le
premier réseau au monde numérique et
après bell il ya quelque chose de
d'absolument vrai dans ce que vous avez
dit c'est que l'incapacité à fixer des
bus qui survivent aux alternances est
une faiblesse et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis alors là pas comme
commissaire au plan mais à titre de
citoyen je suis extrêmement insatisfaits
du fonctionnement de nos institutions
sur un point
si la mécanique classique du
fonctionnement démocratique c'est tous
les cinq ans renverse tout et on passe
de l'autre côté en abandonnent tous les
projets ce sera la vérité chaque
ministre croyant naïvement que il
apporte quelque chose qui n'avait jamais
été abordée avant lui et qu'il va vous
connaissez le disco parce qu'il est tenu
devant chacun d'entre vous le le fait
qu'il n'ya aucune continuité y compris
dans leurs représentations je parle de
l'assemblée nationale est pas du sénat
c'est une faiblesse française
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme
citoyens comme vous savez je soutiens
une loi électorale qui soit 1 électoral
plus juste de continuité et de
conscience enfin générant des consensus
ou capable de générer des consensus
le ce ce perpétuel basculement d'un bord
sur l'autre qui fait que ça fait parti
des faiblesses que la haute
administration considère que le pouvoir
politique ça passe mais que ceux qui
restent en place
c
les hauts fonctionnaires que donc il
suffit d'attendre un peu
assieds toi sur le bord de la rivière et
tu verra passer le cadavre des réformes
oublier comme ça que ça se passe et il
ya là une faiblesse absolument
considérable parce que ça nous empêche
aussi d'entrer dans le long terme et
donc je moi je
comme vous voyez je j'ai majine je vois
notre mode de fonctionnement dans lequel
on est plus de stabilité et moins de
dépendance à l'exécutif pour simplifier
je veux dire l'exécutif à son rôle plein
et entier d'ailleurs il arrive pas à le
remplir
parce qu'il se trouve devant des
obstacles perpétuelle souterrain secret
implicite jamais explicité mais qui font
que on n'y arrive pas et donc alors à
toutes les questions qui touchent à la
reconquête
oui moi je pense qu'il faut vous parliez
de fonds pour la recherche
il faut avoir une capacité
d'investissement de long terme et c'est
l'idée de ce plan marshall
pour la reconquête qui n'est pas de
l'argent perdu
c'est pas de la subvention c'est même
moi je suis très frappé le quand je vois
la chine qu est-ce qui domine quand on
regarde les grands mécanismes
d'investissements réciproques entre la
chine et l'europe c'est très simple vous
ne pouvez pas investir en chine sans
faire de joint-ventures
qu'est ce que ça veut dire venir une
chose très simple c'est vous pouvez
produire chez nous mais nous aurons une
part de l'innovation de transfert de
technologie nous aurons toute la
propriété intellectuelle et nous en face
nous sommes dans une espèce de naïveté
mercantile qui fait que à c'est très
très mal vue d'imposer des prescriptions
ou des précautions de cet ordre et je
suis en désaccord mais radicale avec 7
naïveté intéressés et donc oui je pense
que que nous avons une politique à
produire de ce point de vue là qui fasse
que nous défendions nos propres chances
et nos propres armes
[Musique]
alors madame la varde elle est partie
mais je vais quand même depuis luire lui
remettra il n'est pas vrai que j'ai
jamais pensé qu'aux problèmes de
natalité
la solution était dans l'immigration
jamais je ne crois pas ça pour tout un
tas de raisons la première est numérique
enfin arithmétique bêtement arithmétique
combien y at-il de femmes en âge d'avoir
des enfants en france entre 8 et 10
millions si vous rapportez se chiffre à
l'immigration
alors il faudrait des vagues de 2
d'import de population pour essayer de
rétablir sa je crois pas ça une seconde
je crois que c'est un leurre pour les
uns et un fantasme pour les autres je
pense que
le lac la question de la démographie et
dans l'harmonie d'une société et autant
je pense qu'il faut avoir
une attitude constructive quand on voit
les apports successifs de populations
qui ont eu lieu en france et je crois
qu'il peut y avoir demain un équilibre
de la société y compris avec des apports
l'unité ou en tout cas réguler et
réfléchi je crois pas du tout à ce que
les allemands au fait c'est à dire
accepter d'un seul coup un million de
personnes parce que le patronat allemand
avait dit qu'il fallait un million de
personnes pour des mains d'oeuvre en
plus qu'ils ne trouvaient plus de madame
ça pour moi si c'était si ça se
produisait en france étant donné le la
situation psychologique du pays et les
tensions
je pense que ça ferait des dégâts
considérables qui produirait du
déséquilibre et le déséquilibre produit
de la dénatalité
c'est à dire exactement le contraire
parce que si vous êtes dans une société
dans laquelle les tensions se
multiplient alors les éléments d'une
d'infléchissement de la démographie sont
réunis donc j'ai jamais je ne je ne
pense pas ça j'ai au contraire décrit
dans le dans le rapport le fait que oui
fallait une attitude
il ya aujourd'hui disent les rapports
quelque chose comme entre 15 et 20% de
la natalité qui est dû à des femmes
issues de l'immigration alors qu'il y a
entre 10 et 15% de donc le taux de
fécondité est un peu plus haut mais ça
change pas les laits grand nombre de
donc je donc jeunes donc je ne pense pas
ça je pense au contraire que comme hbo
pour tous les problèmes qui se posent à
la france
la réponse elle est en nous les
difficultés que nous rencontrons les
défis qui se présentent devant nous la
réponse aux questions qui nous sont
posées elle est en nous et si nous
pensons que c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
devons la recevoir
nous nous trompons du tout au tout ça
c'est ma manière de voir les choses à la
raison madame lagarde sur la rupture
entre 5 et 6 ans je viens de parler des
déplacements de populations à bernard
fialaire moi je ne crois pas vous avez
posé les problèmes exactement dans les
termes où on ou les posent depuis 30 ans
ou 50 ans
comme si la limitation à notre appareil
de production était dans la main
d'oeuvre dans la disponibilité de la
main-d'oeuvre dont le coût de la main
d'oeuvre et ça n'est à mes yeux
aujourd'hui que marginalement vrai parce
que on est devant un basculement des
processus de production dans le monde et
ses processus de production sont
désormais directement et julien bargeton
retrouvera là sa préoccupation
directement dépendant de la révolution
numérique
[Musique]